hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from several subscribers it
was suggested you know from time to time
now it was suggested again so I decided
to do a video on it it's a game between
Veselin Topalov and alexis Europe so two
modern magicians and the game is from a
very strongly NARAS tournament of 1998
we found out on another one this
tournament in clear first place with
seven and a half points losing only one
game to Alex a share of here second
place was Alex a hero with seven points
so half of a half point behind Anand and
with six and a half points Vladimir
Kramnik was in third place Garry
Kasparov also played and he won't forced
the fourth place with six and a half
points the same is kramnik and he's the
only one that didn't lose a single game
but he only got one victory and all the
other games were drawn in fifth place
was Peter Svidler sixth place was vastly
manchak and in seventh place was a
Veselin Topalov here so only seven
players in the 1998 Linares tournament
but you know very very interesting
lineup at the end of the tournament and
Anand won that tournament with a rating
performance of twenty eight hundred and
forty that and that was that was a lot I
mean it's a lot today but it was a lot
in those days
definitely so let's see this game by
these two modern magicians top Olaf has
the white pieces and d4 Knight f6 c4 and
g6 the Kings Indian defense Knight to c3
but now Shiro goes for d5 the groom fell
defense see captor son d5 Knight captor
son d5 the exchange variation
efore Knight captures B captures and
Bishop to g7 and here we have seen
mostly in this position people play
Bishop to c4 or maybe Knight to f3
but Shiro goes for Bishop to b5 check c6
and Bishop to a 4-0 castles we have nice
to eat - nice - d7 and stop all of
castles as well
e5 now break trying to break a white
center
f 3 Queen to e7 and Bishop to e3
supporting the d4 pawn rook to d8 Queen
to c2 now getting the Queen out of the
way since the rook aligned aligned up on
the same file nice to be six attacking
the bishop Bishop to b3 Bishop to e6 and
now rook a to d1 rotate to d1 and Knight
to c4
it doesn't do black any good to capture
the bishop or something like that this
only improves White's pawn structure and
if needed the white a white will get the
open a file so I have to rotate the d1
Knight to c4 now going after the bishop
on e3 Bishop to C 1 B 5 and F for now
and here sheriff has probably only two
good options one is to capture the pawn
on d4 the other one is to play f6 if you
want for something like f6 after f5 and
Bishop f7 it's a perfectly fine position
to play for both white and black but
after a fork he decided to go for each
capture song d4 Knight captures on d4
and we have Bishop to g4 now attacking
the rook can be one we have rope detail
one and Queen to c5 now pinning the
knight on d4 King h1 to Paolo
immediately on pins a five now and here
we have h3 attacking the bishop Bishop
d7 and this is something you want to
remember whenever you have phones like
these these this going after your bishop
you can you can play this maneuver a4
and after B characters on a4 simply play
Bishop to a2 so now your Bishop will
stay on this very strong diagonal and
you messed up black's pawn structure for
the price of a pawn but still it's okay
Bishop to 8 + e5 now now Topalov kind of
seizes the initiative here nice to be 6
and we have f5 and it's it's a very
sharp position
Knight to d5 was played and here to
polit had
had an amazing opportunity to go for
something more after Knight to d5 the
pawn on c3 as attacked and the paolo
chose to play Bishop to d2 to defend it
and in a sharp position like this a slow
move like this simply won't to do what
the Polish should have a gun for is rook
to f3 now protecting the c3 pawn and
also a threatening to double up on the F
file and it's not not that easy to find
a move for black here if you look at the
position I mean what do you play here if
you play something like rook 8 b8 which
seems like a normal move you know just
developing f6 is coming and after we
play Bishop to f8 e 6 now you can't
capture the pawn or Knight captures on
e6 for King the Queen and the rook so
after something like rook to b7
defending not really much you can do
I mean a white isn't even that much
that's tempted to push e7 he'll just
enjoy the position
so probably rook e to F 1 doubling up on
the F file and F only after rook to d6
now you push east 7 the bishop has
nowhere to go
all the files are taken the squares are
taken and after Bishop captures F
characters and rook captures simply
Queen to f2 tripling on the F file you
have two two rooks on the Queen
attacking f7 this bishop is also eyeing
f7 it's a very unpleasant position I
mean it's a winning position for white
definitely
so after Knight to d5 to pol of miss the
opportunity of going for rogue to f6
rope to f3 and he decided to defend with
Bishop to d2 but probably due to the
fact that he missed she rose next move
nice to b4 and you can't capture of
course your queen is hanging on c2 and
this will eliminate the pulse light
square bishop and that Bishop is so
strong I mean it literally cuts the
board in half Queen captures on a4 now
grabbing that double bond but from
Knight captures Queen captures and
Bishop captures on e5 so already those 5
+ f5 pawns were
extremely strong there was a light
square bishop on a - slicing the board
in half and now sure of definitely
definitely now has the upper hand F
captures and g6 we have H captures on g6
and Bishop to g5 attacking the rook rook
to d5 rook to e3 Queen to d6 Queen to e2
and now Bishop to d7 now a slow move by
Shiro and here it's actually the polyp
that again misses the opportunity the
idea here he played c4 attacking the
rook on d5 but the the best the best
idea for the palette here is nice to f3
attacking the bishop three times and
after something like Bishop to g3 only
then pushed c4 and this actually leads
to a pretty long variation but it's it's
not a problem
for example rook to f5 rook to d1 now
attacking the Queen you have to defend
the bishop on d7 so after Queen to c7
not going for rook to e7 immediately but
for example Queen to be - now eyeing
that g7 threatening ideas like Bishop h6
the to give checkmate on h7 so that's
for something like Bishop to f4 black
has to get rid of the dark square Bishop
now it's not in play rook to e7 now with
a double attack on the d7 Bishop so
after Bishop captures on g5 knife
captors on g5 you don't capture the
night because then rook captures on d7
and you have you have problems on f7 g7
so after Queen to f4 Knight captures on
f7 rook captures and outro captures on
b7 rook a to f8 now rook captures rook
captures and at the end of this why it's
a pretty long variation but nothing
nothing to Paul or Shiro couldn't handle
it's a slightly better position for
white the material is equal but White
has two point islands Black has three so
definitely playable for Apollo's but
after Bishop to d7 he played he didn't
go Knight of three and then c4 he played
the immediate
for but now sheriff has better
characters on d4 because the night is on
d4 C capture Sun d5 Bishop captures rook
on e3 Queen captures and now rook to e8
first getting rid of the Queen Queen c3
and now Queen captures on d5 top olive
goes for Bishop to h6 with some threats
of Queen to g7 checkmate butter up to e5
defending rope to f3 now Queen to c5
offering a trade of Queens as opposed to
that other variation I've shown where
the material was equal here sheriff is
up to pawns Queen to a-1 Bishop to f5
and rook to e3
we have f6 rook captures Queen captures
and now Queen to a2 with Czech Queen to
d5 blocking and here the paula was
expecting this and he decides to capture
Queen captures C capture Sun d5 and now
we reached an opposite color Bishop to
end game where shiro is up two pawns so
you know a lot a lot of times you hear
that opposite colored bishop and games
are always a draw but this is definitely
I mean it's not the case most most
opposite color Bishop and games aren't
drawn you just have to really find a way
how to win
Bishop to d2 we have a for now Bishop
the c3 going for the f6 pawn king f 7h
for now top olive needs his pawns to be
on the dark squares King e6 we have pink
to g1 and here we have this is the
position and this is the move many
consider to be the greatest chess move
ever made in history so do give it a
couple of seconds even pause the video
if you'd like and try to find what shear
of played in this position a lot of
people say that you know if if you say
pause the video you don't have to give
people a couple of seconds but I I give
you a couple of seconds just so you can
decide whether you want to pause the
video but okay I'm sure you already did
if you found it
I mean I remember I saw this position
like three or four years ago
and I didn't I didn't find it so those
of you who did congratulations and even
even the engine doesn't recommend this
move or anything here sheriff played
Bishop to h3 and it's a it's a weird
move indeed you give up your only piece
and for the price of doubling up
doubling up white spawns and G captures
on h3 top all of accepts this
what was she rubs idea if a Topalov
declined this offer I don't know what
would happen if if something like King F
2 was played probably not probably still
winning but it'd be interesting how he
does it so G captures on h3 was played
and now King to f5 King F 2 came to e4
we have Bishop captures on f6 and now
counts d4 Bishop to e7 and King to d3
Bishop to c5 and King to c4 Bishop to e7
and here King to b3 and in this position
a vessel in T'Pol resigned the game so
after that Bishop sacrifice was accepted
it's a pretty it's pretty clear path to
victory
I don't know I'm okay probably there was
time trouble and everything but it's
it's definitely a nice move and I didn't
find it so hopefully some of you did
what would happen here was some it would
be something like Bishop to c5 d3 now
a king has to stop the pawn but after
king c2 and Bishop b4
the problem is you can't stop both bonds
simply a3 sacrifice one point and an
output D - you can stop promotion Bishop
e7 and now upon 2 d1 Queen so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and what do you think of the move does
it justify the title greatest movie ever
made in chess history if not just you
know right no no it doesn't so yeah I
would like to thank Joshua Jones for a
contribution to my channel think a lot
to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I
we'll see soon